[Music]
from the Adam Sandler Employment Agency
comes a happy Madison film without the
Sandman in it so instead of a lavish
free vacation you and Kevin James will
never see the outside of this mall for
the rest of your natural life hul Blart
Mall Cop what if Die Hard happened to a
rent a cop instead of John mlan
would be a good setup for a comedy but
since this is a happy medicine joint
prepare for the most half-ass version
possible with unconvincing bad guys why
don't we just start wasting hostages
that'll stop them sucky
action and popsicle stick level punch
lines hey you scuba Dooby
dooo but just like the sabaro in a food
court if you pay to see paulb mup you
get what you deserve you absolute [__]
I don't understand why you're laughing I
just called you fat I'm not
laughing meet Paul Blart he is fat I've
had some issues with weight myself I
didn't have to go online Paul to know
that you love peanut brittle let's face
it son you present a huge
Target time for some big game hunting
because he loves food get the pite now
[Applause]
oh you know if you're doing the sloppy
joe do the sweet potato
fries oh yeah that's a good stuff and
you're not going to believe this but
he's sad inside peanut butter it just
fills the cracks of the heart let's face
it we need to fill a void right just
don't let that Define him okay because
he's also
[Music]
clumsy fou f
ow and sweaty I will edit out the sweaty
Parts I am sweaty but I'm not I'm not
sweating over anyone oh here come the
love sweats and
pathetic she married you got citizenship
and then she left us we used to abuse
that loser in high school give me that
back
up you can't pass the trooper exam you
black out if you don't have a Snickers
bar like every 20 minutes sadly that was
too much for PA 2 where he is back to
Simply fat we have left over bake
ziti you requested a bottomless bowl of
Peanut
M&M's yeah s out craps that guy ruined
it if you're wearing a polyester shirt
with Spanx
underneath remember the segue it's back
in joke form you're going to pull up
left hip forward enjoy the turd scooters
breakthrough moment in a film that like
the rest of the world couldn't decide if
they were
[Music]
dorky or
awesome but man did this film think they
were
funny sorry but the only good segue joke
is the one you feel laughing at an Aeris
shines as the Charming M staffer on whom
our hero develops a massive Crush in the
other 2009 comedy about a mop who gets
in over his head it's a little
darker no this romantic interest is ISA
Fisher or uh no it's the other one J
something from Glee anyway she reminds
Paul Bart of food so he stuffs her in
his mouth at the end see guys stalking
works so ring in in the season with a
rare Black Friday movie that channels
the holiday spirit by wasting 90 minutes
of your time outside of chain stores and
plays out exactly like Adam Sandler's
movie career terrible the vast majority
of the time inexplicably good once or
twice then back to being terrible
again see it's funny cuz the dog
died starring Kevin can't himself M rat
hell to pay small Bart surely you can't
be serious she's out of your league the
swatcher the final dab Allan and what
every Kevin James movie should include
his brother singing Boni as a Bill
Bailey look
alike High
hard sure he's a little thick but he
takes down this fence in 30 fewer Cuts
than Liam
niss
Maul Blart Paul cop bum is on the cheese
bum is on the cheese and if I am lucky
I'll catch a disease Legend has it that
if epic voice gu reads 10 of your
comments you get a free cookie I'm doing
this the oldfashioned way by running in
the opposite direction